seven months into the rail dispute
there's still no resolution today two
sides in the conflict addressed MPS
unions the rmt as left and the tssa and
the employers who get their mandate from
ministers Network Rail and the rail
delivery Group which represents train
operators and they had very different
expectations of whether a deal can be
done
I think you include zero and you're one
to ten and we're near them we're further
away than when we started I I I'd place
that to seven
now Network rail made an offer to the
rmt Before Christmas offering five
percent on pay last year and four
percent this year with no compulsory
redundancies until 2025 but that's
conditional on compulsory Sunday working
and changes to conditions including
maintenance teams now 64 of rmt members
rejected this deal but the tssa union
accepted the same offer saying it was
the best they could expect thrill
delivery group made its own offer to the
rmt that was worth four percent last
year and four percent this with no
compulsory redundancies until April next
year but was contingent on more Sunday
working and crucially Driver only
operation that's trains without guards a
long-standing red line for unions and
the rmt dismissed it without a ballot
the driver's Union as left is expected
to do the same when it considers the
deal formally on Monday now unions say
they will never accept driver only
operation and its inclusion in payoff as
proves ministers deliberately wanted to
derail these talks
they let the strikes go ahead over
Christmas they didn't lift the telephone
or lift the finger to get them off the
whole thing has been completely stage
managed leading up to one of these
sessions of the trade unions as far as I
can see so it's a deliberate torpedoing
of the talks since the pandemic
government has been in control of the
railways passing the revenue risk to
taxpayers but the transport secretary
says he does want a deal
I'd facilitated offers to go to the
trade unions I wanted them to sit down
with the employers talk through those
details look at the reform package and
try and get to a solution and not have
the strikes for all the posturing of the
last week there may now be a window for
fresh negotiations but to be meaningful
the unions say it has to start with
ministers